A couple of videos ago we
figured out how to go from the
empirical formula to the
mass composition.
And all I mean by that, mass
composition, is that you could
start with the empirical formula
H2O, which is also its
molecular formula.
And then we were able to figure
out what percentage of
this was water and what
percentage of this was hydrogen.
The way we did it is we said,
OK, oxygen's mass is 16 atomic
mass units.
Hydrogen is one.
The mass of the entire molecule
is 2 times hydrogen.
2 times 1.
Plus 16 for that one
oxygen, so it's 18.
And then we said, the
composition of
oxygen is just 16/18.
So oxygen is 16/18.
I don't have my calculator
anymore.
I think the number was something
on the order of 88%
or 88.9% oxygen.
So now let's see if we
can go the other way.
Let's see if we could start
with mass composition, the
percent composition of the
different elements, and then
go to empirical formula.
And I think the first
video I made, I
spelled empirical wrong.
Which is good reason for me
not to do spelling videos.
I think I spelled this with
an e right here, because I
pronounce it empricial.
But it's spelled with an i.
Empirical formula.
So back to the empirical
formula.
So let's do some exercises
here to see
if we can get someplace.
So let's say that I start off
with-- I need space, my
periodic table is right
down there.
Let's say I am told that
I have a bag of stuff.
And 75% of that bag, let's
say it is mercury.
Hg.
And say that the other 25%
of the bag is chlorine.
So the question that I'm asked
is, what is the empirical
formula of the stuff that I have
here, assuming that it's
all one molecule or one
type of molecule?
So what is the empirical
formula?
So the way to think about this
is, let's assume that you have
100 grams of this stuff.
Right?
And the reason why I'm picking
100 is because 100 is a useful
number to deal with.
So if I have 100 grams of
the stuff, all right.
So let's say I assume that you
have 100 grams. If you have
100 grams, how many grams
of mercury do you have?
Well that means that 75% of
that, that means you have 75
grams of mercury, Hg.
And that means you have
25 grams of chlorine.
You might be saying, where did
get these numbers from?
Well, I got the numbers because
I assumed 100 grams. I
could have assumed 112 grams
or 7 grams, but those would
have been harder numbers
to work with.
So I'm just assuming 100 grams.
So the question is, in
75 grams of mercury, how many
moles of mercury do I have?
So I need to convert from
grams to moles.
Let's go the other way.
One mole of mercury-- this is at
least how my brain thinks--
let me pick a suitable color--
so one mole of mercury so 6.02
times 10 to the 23
mercury atoms.
What's the mass of that?
Well it's equal to whatever
mercury's mass number is in
grams. So let's go look up
mercury's mass number.
So mercury is a transition
metal.
It's one of the few metals
that are liquid at room
temperature.
Right there we have mercury.
Its mass number, let's
pick the 200.
It has a mass number of 200.
Obviously, there's some mercury
out there that has a
mass of 201.
But for simplicity, let's
say it's 200.
So 1 mole of mercury is 200
grams. How did I get that?
Mercury's mass number.
One atom of mercury has a mass
of 200 atomic mass units.
So one mole of mercury-- 6.02
times 10 to the 23 mercury
atoms-- has that many
grams of mass.
So instead of 200 atomic mass
units per atom, we have 200
grams per mole of that atom.
It's an easy calculation.
You just look up it atomic mass
number and say it's that
many grams. You have a mole
of the substance.
Fair enough.
And what about one
mole of chlorine?
We do the same exercise.
We go down to our
periodic table.
Chlorine has a mass number
of, let's say, 35.
It has various isotopes
on this planet.
But let's say the mass
number is 35.
So one chlorine atom weighs--
well now, we shouldn't say
weighs, we have to
be very careful.
One chlorine atom has a mass
of 35 atomic mass units.
So 6.02 times 10 to the 23
chlorine atoms, or one mole of
chlorine atoms will
have a mass of 35.
35 grams.
So how many moles of
mercury do I have?
Let me get my calculator
going.
So I have 75 grams of mercury.
One mole of mercury would have
a mass of 200 grams. So I
could just take 75 divided by
200 and it tells me how many
moles I have. 75 divided
by 200 is equal to
0.375 moles of mercury.
How did I figure that?
One mole of mercury would be
200 grams. I only have 75
grams of mercury, so I have a
small fraction of it, roughly
0.375 moles of mercury.
I've just expressed the number
of atoms of mercury I have.
Moles tells me it's 6.02 times
10 to the 23 atoms of mercury.
So I have 0.375 times Avogadro's
number of mercury
atoms. Fair enough.
Now let's do the chlorine.
I have 25 grams of chlorine.
One mole of chlorine
is 35 grams. So I
have 25 over 35 moles.
So what's that?
So 25 divided by 35 is equal
to 0.714 moles of chlorine.
Now these numbers, they're
not exact.
Because if you take twice this
number up here, you don't get
twice this number right here.
If you get twice this,
you don't get this.
But this is roughly twice as
many moles of chlorine as I do
of mercury.
So that tells me that for every
mercury atom-- remember,
moles is just a number-- for
every mercury atom I have, I
have two chlorine atoms. So the
empirical formula here is
for every mercury I have
two chlorines.
I have two chlorines,
right there.
And the numbers didn't work
out almost exactly right.
Especially in the real world,
when you're actually trying to
figure out things empirically,
your numbers seldom will.
And maybe there's some random
other things running out there
in terms of other things that
are contributing to the mass.
But this is close enough to know
that the ratio of mercury
to chlorine is roughly 1:2.
Right?
This is a number.
For every one chlorine atom,
you have roughly two.
You have twice as many.
I guess the other way of
thinking about it is you have
twice as many chlorine
atoms in the
bag as you have mercury.
Roughly.
Although this is a
little bit more.
This is close to 0.75.
But it's close enough for you
to know that you're dealing
with mercury chloride.
Right there.
Let's do another one of these.
Let's see how the numbers
turn out for this one.
Let's say you have another
bag that is 9% magnesium.
And let's say the remainder of
the bag, 91%, is iodine.
91% is iodine.
So the way to do all of these
is, you do the same thing.
Assume you have 100 grams. So
if you have 100 grams, of
which you have 9 grams
of magnesium.
And you have 91 grams
of iodine.
And then figure out how much a
mole of magnesium-- what would
be the mass of a mole
of magnesium and
then a mole of iodine.
So let me write here.
One mole of magnesium.
And we want to figure out
one mole of iodine.
Let's figure those out.
So magnesium's mass number is,
let's just go with 24.
Let's say we have the
isotope that's 24.
Magnesium is 24 and since
we're already down here,
what's iodine.
127.
It's 127.
Iodine is one of the halogens.
So let's see.
You have 127 and you have 24.
Let me write those down.
So you have 127 and
you have 24.
So one atom of iodine has a mass
of 127 atomic mass units.
So a whole mole all of it, 6.02
times 10 to the 23 iodine
atoms will have a mass of 127
grams. You just take the
atomic weight, or the atomic
mass, and the mass will be
that many grams when you have
this many of the atom.
So then one mole of magnesium
will be 24 grams.
So now we just figure out how
many moles of each of these we
have. We have 9 grams
of magnesium.
So what fraction of
a mole is that?
A mole is 24 grams. So
this is equal to
9/24 moles of magnesium.
And what is 9 over 24?
9 divided by 24 is
equal to 0.375.
So this is equal to 0.375, which
is similar to what we
had in the last problem when
that 0.375 showed up.
And 91 grams of iodine
is what?
91 grams of iodine.
Well, in a whole mole of iodine
you're going to have
127 grams. So we have 91/127
moles of iodine.
And what's 91 over 127?
I have a feeling we're going to
have very similar numbers.
121 divided by 127 is
equal to 0.716.
I should do another problem with
better ratios than this.
These have the same ratios as
the last problem, 0.72,
roughly, moles of iodine.
And this is moles
of magnesium.
So we have roughly twice the
number of iodine atoms as we
do of magnesium atoms. Right?
For every one magnesium atom
we have roughly two iodine
atoms. I know this isn't
exactly 1:2,
but it's pretty close.
So the formula here is
magnesium iodide.
Right there.
And that's the empirical
formula.
We don't know, maybe in every
atom maybe you had two
magnesiums and four iodines.
We don't know.
All we know is that the
ratio of magnesium to
iodine here is 1:2.
In the next video, I'm going to
try to look for ones that
have more interesting ratios,
because I don't want to do two
problems that both have
the same ratio.
But hopefully you found this
a little bit helpful.